oh to be this dumb
when you see um entire media companies
essentially exist
to tear down joe biden is there an
equivalent to that on the left tearing
down trump
uh there really isn't and you know what
i would say it it's
it's really a diet of this type of
information that a lot of these voters
are getting
so so wait there's no anti-trump network
wow even cnn admits nobody watches cnn
but look even if you despise trump you
gotta admit this deception
dares you to laugh in its face there
isn't an anti-trump media company
hell there might be two dozen with cnn
leading the hair on fire pack
the only reason every trump book goes to
number one is because it has two cable
networks doing its pr
which explains why two recent massive
surveys say
media is overwhelmingly biased and
cannot be trusted
if only this delusional thinking were
relegated to the silly world of politics
or brian stelter's head
but it's not the same people who deny
this reality
deny a lot of far uglier facts rising
murder rates
shootings looting property destruction
attacks on the elderly
killings by released felons attacks on
free speech
riots described as peaceful protests and
remember how the media pretended that
defunding the police was a
reasonable ask for this to succeed they
had a bury reality
like gallup's survey showing that over
80 percent of blacks and hispanics
want the same amount or more police
funny how the white anchors never bring
that stuff up but in order for a
left-wing view of the world to exist
you must pretend none of that other bad
stuff exists
meaning the consequences of left-wing
action and democratic leader
inaction you can thank a media in the
left working together
to preserve their power meanwhile
stelter also denies the reality of joe
biden's decline
this is joe biden out there on a
vigorous
bike ride not wearing a helmet but
definitely wearing a mask by the way
fox's narrative and ray talk radio's
narrative for months
has been that joe biden is falling apart
you just heard ben shapiro say it
falling apart and there he is riding a
bike
out for a bike ride cool so if you ride
a bike you can be
president that's good news for these
fellas
yep check him out you know i got my
money on the pug
what can i say he's got a sound fiscal
policy
thank you dana for the courtesy laugh so
i shall go to you first
how can anybody say there are no
anti-trump networks with a straight face
is that literally that is the literal
definition of denial
i i hope i wasn't disrupting your read
of
your monologue because i was laughing
through the entire thing um when i saw
the topic for today i thought this is
just
like basically they just make material
for you for your monday monologues right
over there um there are absolutely
entire networks devoted to it
and there have been there have been from
the beginning
well really not until after he won right
if you remember
some of them were helpful to him when he
was a candidate morning joe and then
they changed their tune
right the other thing is that if that's
a vigorous bike ride
i would really like to see the
candidates have to
go on kindle tools 45 minutes intervals
and arms
yes and then we'll find out if they have
vigorous bike rides you know i did a
tabata ride yesterday the 15 minute one
it's perfect
it's just the right amount of time so
dagon
whenever anybody describes some some
action
as vigorous it's it's a dog whistle for
being old
it's like it's like saying oh look how
spry he is he went he got he went right
up those stairs
look he put two sentences together here
bravo joe biden um
i don't i you know i i always learned if
you can't say something nice about
somebody or an entire network don't say
anything at all so i'll just sit here
and do an audition for cnn
with a sneer on my face and my mouth
again like that
because that's the equivalent of what
you get they did
armchair psychoanalysis of president
trump for how many years
well i would it's not really armchair
it's more like sandbox while they're
eating
the you know what the cat left behind in
the sand
i i i get nothing from this it is the
equivalent of a toddler eating toilet
paper
not you but the other guy we would not
advise that at all
right lawrence we've all we've we all
work in tv
i envisioned that there were people in
the control room where the producers and
the directors work
who just burst out laughing when they
hear somebody say something like that
they go
don't you work at cnn
i mean honestly the sad part about it is
i actually feel like they believed this
which is
really telling yeah um but but we laugh
at this but
when you're looking at this from a
logical standpoint this is hurtful to
their candidate joe biden
um he's not prepared for debates he's
not prepared for real
real questions i mean it seems like
every week we spend time
because the president has done some big
interview and we have to pick it apart
as we should because he's the president
of the united states he's running for
reelection
but we never have that opportunity to do
that for joe biden
because he doesn't do those type of
interviews and when he does do a layup
interview
we always have to talk about his gaffes
and his response to every tough question
is come on man and that that's telling
because
there's gonna come a point where he has
to be on the debate stage
he'll get some prep but he's not gonna
be ready for some of those questions
because
he hasn't been interviewed those
questions should come
before the debate stage and he hasn't
been able to answer those and i don't
think he's going to be able to answer
them on the debate stage either
yeah donna i saved the best for last
uh shouldn't joe a very old
white male if he was truly not racist
step aside and allow a woman of color to
become president
by not stepping aside isn't he
reaffirming the subtle racism that we've
seen him express
over the past year with his commentary
about blacks
well he started off the segment you
started off the segment talking about
the media and bias and i was going to
tell you that
if you look at the last five years
there's been an increased
polarization in the media just like it
is in our politics in our culture
so let's put that aside the second thing
lawrence he's done 100 interviews and
while
they're not all perfect at least he's
done 100 and he participated in at least
12 debates during the democratic primary
so maybe he doesn't
answer the questions the way you like to
hear the answer but he
is uh capable of holding his on
uh with like when he said last week that
black folks
weren't diverse lawrence if i if i
comment on everything president
trump has said over the last four years
uh we do no you don't
you don't you you you whitewash and
airbrush what trump says
everything but here's the point i want
to make uh
we're going to get to see joe biden and
and donald trump two
men in their 70s and by the way um i
don't think
70 is old i know that some of you do
but i do believe that if he is if he's
up for the job
and he can handle the job just like
president reagan was able to handle the
job
and uh president trump then let's debate
the merits of their proposals and
in their issues that's that's
this is why biden isn't ready because
every single time we have a conversation
about
biting hysterics and people that support
him go to president trump
uh he's got to be able to defend what
his ideology is but he does
lawrence lawrence help me on your show
and i can i can break it i can break it
down
so well so that when you talk about joe
biden
and his racism i could tell you about
trump and his racism because
it's white supremacy we're fighting not
just white candidates okay
all right i'm ready for you white
supremacy everywhere